bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches c'est
l'heure du bilan dans un bilan
normalement il ya de l'actif et du
passif
là j'ai peur qu'il n'y ait que du passif
bonjour à tous et bienvenue puis dans
ces caches c'est l'un des thèmes majeurs
du débat à quelques mois de la
présidentielle entre flambée des prix de
l'énergie est sortie de crise sanitaire
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages est
devenu un sujet central alors quel effet
le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
aura-t-il eu sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages français plus globalement on va
passer en revue les mesures fiscales et
sociales prises ces cinq dernières
années avec vous olivier bonjour bonjour
fun et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre sabatier bonjour vous êtes
économiste membre d econoclaste et
président du cabinet prime view vient
bonjour là bonjour aujourd'hui leur
10,2 milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages français voici ce
que prévoit le nouveau projet de budget
pour 2022 il a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale et poursuit son
parcours parlementaire les dernières
mesures donc a priori du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron alors qui sont les
gagnants et les perdants de la politique
fiscale et sociale du chef de l'état
éléments de réponse avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine basse
[Musique]
ça y est l'heure du bilan approche car
avec les dernières mesures du
gouvernement amorcé dans le budget 2022
on a maintenant un aperçu global de
l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat sur le
quinquennat et attention suspense la
politique d' emmanuel macron a profité
avant tout aux plus riches
a croire qu entendre sans arrêt macron
président des riches bla bla bla bah en
fait c'était vrai selon une étude de
l'institut des politiques publiques les
1% les plus riches ont vu leur pouvoir
d'achat augmenter de 2,8 pour cent sur
le quinquennat mieux les 0,1 pour cent
les ultra riches et ben ça monte à 4 %
alors que les 5 % des ménages les plus
pauvres eux l'ont vu baisser de 0,5 pour
cent pour ce qui est des plus aisés
cette hausse s'expliquerait par des
mesures comme la transformation de
l'impôt sur la fortune en impôts sur la
fortune immobilière ou la mise en place
du prélèvement forfaitaire unique pour
les moins aisés en revanche la hausse de
la fiscalité sur le tabac ou les prix de
l'énergie des domaines qui pèse un
certain poids dans leurs revenus ont
fait dégringoler leur pouvoir d'achat et
les dernières mesures contre l'inflation
et la hausse des prix de l'énergie à
quelques mois des élections ne pourront
pas inverser la tendance
emmanuel macron pourra toujours se
consoler en se disant que mis à part les
plus pauvres ceux qui sont le plus dans
le besoin tous les autres ont vu leur
pouvoir d'achat augmenter une hausse
moyenne globale pour tous les français
de 1,6 pour cent des chiffres qui font
mal à l'exécutif à quelques mois de
l'échéance présidentielle
emmanuel macron tente d'ailleurs depuis
plusieurs semaines de se défaire de
cette image de président des riches
surtout lorsqu'on sait que le pouvoir
d'achat est l'une des plus grosses
préoccupations des français
d'après cette étude donc de l'institut
des politiques publiques globalement la
majorité des français a vu son pouvoir
d'achat a augmenté de 1,6 pour cent par
an en moyenne depuis 2007 sauf les 5 %
de ménages les plus modestes c'est à
dire ceux qui vivent avec moins de 800
euros par mois qu'ils ont eu a perdu
jusqu'à 0 5 % de pouvoir d'achat pour
autant olivier peut-on affirmer qu
emmanuel macron a été le président des
riches déjà on va un il faut revenir sur
ce chiffre 1,6 pour cent c'est un
chiffre qui est calculée avec
l'inflation officielle
vous savez que l'inflation officielle
n'a rien à voir avec le coût de la vie
et que donc vous êtes en fait à en perte
de pouvoir d'achat depuis depuis plus de
cinq ans d'ailleurs pas seulement mallié
qui est responsable de ça vous en avez
une autre avant
simplement parce qu'on a toujours
sous-évalué le rythme de l'inflation et
donc on peut vous chantez que le pouvoir
d'achat a augmenté
la réalité c'est qu'il abaissait parce
que vous êtes en gros vous avez une
inflation officiel qui est à moins de 2
ou autour de deux ça dépend des années
qui est à moins 2 or le coût de la vie
lui augmente en général sur un rythme
qui est plutôt proche de 5 à 6% donc si
vous comptez l'immobilier si vous
comptez là la vraie part de l'immobilier
dans l'inflation si vous comptez
certains secteurs qui sont on vous
l'avait dit on avait fait une émission
sur l'inflation on a expliqué qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de techniques
pour sous-évalué la passion qui est un
chiffre politique de marketing politique
et donc ce qui permet de vous annoncer
fièrement que vous avez eu un pouvoir
d'achat qui a augmenté or c'est faux
malheureusement et donc
déjà le postulat de départ n'étant pas
bons je ne peux pas vous expliquer
pourquoi monsieur macron a
en réalité en revanche en réalité la la
le pouvoir d'achat l'huile dé 0 1% là
sur ullrich a énormément augmenté il
suffit simplement de voir le la
capitalisation boursière de titres comme
lvmh pour comprendre que monsieur
bernard non mais pas celui qui à mon
avis on a le plus contre monsieur macron
sur les cinq dernières années hier
sébastien est ce qu'on peut taxer le
chef de l'état de président des riches
la réponse est oui de manière évidente
mais en soi c'est plutôt capital versus
travail et donc ça revient presque insu
à un débat enfin un héritage de son
prédécesseur puisqu'il avait vraiment
érigé la notion de conflit entre capital
et travail un peu comme cela de manière
un peu désuète puisque c'est un débat
des années 70 du temps du communisme
versus capitalisme mais là pour le coup
le vrai sujet c'est que les gilets
jaunes il aurait dû être le lendemain de
son élection quasiment dans la rue parce
qu'effectivement avec la flat tax à la
flat tax c'est quoi ces bas grosso modo
refaire de la france pas un paradis
fiscal gérait pas jusque là mais en tant
en termes de taux d'imposition marginal
sur les revenus du capital en fait un
cadeau associe en fait aux plus riches
qui fait qu' on a un double phénomène
pendant le mandat de d'emmanuel macron
une banque centrale qui a piloté les
marchés financiers pour qu'il s'apprécie
donc ça on a administré les prix les
actifs financiers
évidemment que possèdent les ovins % et
blu ray donc ils se sont enrichis en
termes de capital et en même temps on a
allégé la fiscalité uniquement sur ce
biais on ne veut à travers la flat tax
pour cette population là donc c'est
évident le + 4 % traduit pas une réalité
c'est beaucoup plus que plus qu'elle
pour 101 pour course pour ces personnes
là parce que ben voilà on a fait le
choix du capital versé ce travail parce
que sur le travail qu'est ce qu'il est
qu'est ce qui était fait absolument rien
et entendus par les pouvoirs d'achat
pour pouvoir d'achat qui sait maintenir
le pouvoir d'achat ou arrivé à 1,6 pour
cent et encore on pourrait interroger la
réalité des pays plus 1,6 pour cent à
travers plus de dépenses publiques est
une forme de béquille parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à rémunérer plus les gens
pour qu'ils disposent de suffisamment
d'argent pour pouvoir vivre ou survivre
elle concrètement c'est un échec et donc
ça pose en fait la question fondamentale
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour avoir du
pouvoir d'achat partagé pour la plus
grande masse est bien la seule manière
de faire c'est une activité privée
dynamique il permet de distribuer des
revenus suffisants pour faire face au
coût de la vie et la réalité c'est que
sur ce plan rien n'a été fait pour ça on
a divisé la population en sont-ils du
plus pauvre au plus riche on voit par
exemple avec ce graphique que ceux du
5ème et 6ème sentent ils ont par exemple
bénéficié d'une hausse de leur niveau de
vie de 2% avec l'allocation de
solidarité aux personnes âgées 2% de
hausse aussi pour les populations entre
le dixième donc d'écrire de vente il
avec la prime d'activité tout n'a pas
été fait que pour les dames et voulait
plus investir c'est que tant qu'on rend
sortira pas de ce débat où est on le
voit bien à la veille des élections
c'est bizarre on ressent chéquier
comme tout si c'est pas acheter d'une
certaine manière alors là pour le coup
pas la paix sociale ça marche pas
d'ailleurs partout mais si c'est pas à
chier quelque chose là haut où la
proximité d'une érection amène à ce
qu'on ressorte le chéquier pour
justement booster un petit peu le
pouvoir d'achat mais encore une fois la
question du pouvoir d'achat d'une
question secondaire la question c'est
quelle est l'origine des revenus des
ménages pour en fait maintenir là pour
assurer leur niveau de vie bien il ya
deux manière d'assurer services et ce
pour ada chasser les revenus je me
répète ou les cadeaux ou les soutiens
mais imaginez bien qu'à terme les
soutiens ils pourront pas être maintenue
une manière éternelle quand vous parlez
en fait de primes pour le logement de
primes d'activité etc tout ça sont des
béquilles public parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à avoir une économie privée qui
génère suffisamment de richesses pour
rémunérer bien tout le monde donc vous
fait dire ce que voulaient au chiffre
mais c'est facile de dire on augmente le
pouvoir d'achat et encore il faudrait
rentrer dans le détail comme le faisait
au lit et tout à l'heure mais ses
facilités en augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat en faisant des chèques public
parce que le chèque public c'est vous
qui faites un chèque c'est olivier qui
fait un chèque c'est moi qui fais un
chèque on pourra peut-être pas faire des
chèques en permanence donc d'une
certaine manière la question
fondamentale c'est pas le niveau de
pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui c'est la
capacité à le maintenir durablement dans
le temps un niveau suffisant et donc si
on utilise le ville sinon de la dette
publique la dépense publique donc de la
dette publique pour le faire une chose
est certaine c'est dans l'horizon de 5 à
10 ans pour a pu le faire donc on aura
soutenu artificiellement pendant un
temps parce qu'on est dans l'incapacité
de générer suffisamment de richesse je
me répète pour distribuer des revenus
suffisants alors son avis opération en
faisant en instaurant des béquilles
public qui ne sont pas pérennes en
concrètement c'est reculer pour mieux
sauter la réalité de la capacité de
l'économie française à dix trouver
suffisamment de revenus à l'ensemble de
sa population pour qu'elle vive
correctement c'est qu'elle se dégrade et
sa direction c'est un jeu de bonneteau
parce que qu'ils payent c'est nous
donc quand vous faites de la dette pour
justement faire des chèques l'échec
c'est nous qui les faisons au final
alors peut-être pas tout de suite s'il
bien l'intérêt de la dette d'ailleurs
c'est que ça vous permet de décaler les
choses mais ça veut dire que à un moment
ou à un autre la la la dette va revenir
en impôts donc ça fera baisser la tête
voire d'un chat certaines émissions oui
c'est la mairie justement c'est le sait
le sujet c'est à dire que c'est bien de
distribuer des cadeaux mais si si les
cadeaux étaient distribués par un
chinois d'accord mais là si c'est en
fait on nous oblige à donner les cadeaux
c'est à dire que c'est nous qui les gens
les cadeaux et on nous dit mais c'est
pour vous protéger oui mais moi je veux
choisir de me protéger à à tel ou tel
moment mais j'ai pas besoin de l'état
pour me dire à un moment eh bien on va
bloquer les prix sur sur le gazon va
vous donner un chèque qui va
correspondre à un plein donc je vous
rassure c'est pas c'est pas ça qui va
changer la vie des gens mais tout ça on
sait bien que c'est pour acheter des
voix pour autre chose d'accord donc ils
achètent des voix clairement et mais
simplement il ya un moment où il va
falloir sortir la carte bleue pour les
payer ces cadeaux et qui va les sortir
et quand on va les sortir alors
évidemment après les élections je vous
rassure donc mais on les sortira de
toute façon et revenant à cela tout de
même ça traduit quand même c'est pour ça
qu'il faut pas se tromper de débat le
vrai sujet c'est la capacité de créer
les conditions d'expression du potentiel
de nos concitoyennes aux entreprises aux
créer de la richesse naturellement 5 on
est justement active une machine à
imprimer des 1000 donc pour les
distribuer pour faire survivre mais la
réalité c'est que c'est quand même on
fait face à l'échec patent de notre
économie a créé à s'autosuffire en
termes de création de richesse c'est
quand même on fait face à l'échec de nos
filières d'approvisionnement sire que
des années alors c'est pas que macro
mais refait gamme des décennies d'échec
quant à théo fait qu'on a suivi de
manière assez moutonnière tout ce
qu'elle fait tout le monde en
délocalisant et où tout pourquoi pas
certaines choses mais pas tous et on se
rend compte qu'aujourd'hui on ait des
problèmes d'approvisionnement sur des
choses qui sont centrales pratiquent en
fait dans notre pays aujourd'hui on n'en
dispose plus c'est pareil pour l'énergie
lent qu'on parle notre dépendance aux
autres en termes d'énergies fossiles
c'est nouveau ça fait des années des
décennies je rappelle tout de même que
les années 70 c'est notre investissement
dans le nucléaire était une conséquence
du pic pétrolier de l'époque c'était il
ya quoi ya 40 ans 50 ans eh bien on n'a
rien fait depuis et donc on se retrouve
dans la même situation expose de
dépendance aux autres dire que tout ça
c'est quand même l'échec et banco pour
faire face à ça qu'est ce qu'on fait eh
bien on fait de la dette pour donner des
chèques aux gens pour payer en plein un
plan qui sera loin de cette suffisants
pour faire face à la hausse des prix
tout ça à mon année vous qu'on parle de
diagnostic et de bilan y'a pas de de
diagnostic une bilan qui est positive et
optimiste ou pessimiste il ya un
diagnostic à réaliste et donc il faut
poser le diagnostic ce diagnostic
réaliste de l'échec global notre
économie a créé suffisamment d'activités
pour s'auto suffire et du fait que
depuis des années et des décennies ont
fait des chèques en blanc en termes de
dépenses publiques pour romain tenir
cette situation de déséquilibre stable
en fait vous êtes en train de me dire
que peu importe que la politique fiscale
et sociale menée par le quinquennat de
macron ont fini au final les dés sont
déjà jetés ce que c'est tentant de dire
j'ai tant qu'on n'aura pas remis
l'église au milieu du village à savoir
on dit que une pour qu'une société
affiche de la croissance à travers son
tissu économique privé elle doit le
faire et pas en finn ensemble avec de la
dette publique cette activité est bien
concrètement nous ne faisons que reculer
pour mieux sauter dire que le mur nous
sommes encore en train de construire de
plus en plus près c'est un mur de dette
qu'il faudra un jour à un moment donné
affronter donc parce qu'on n'est pas en
capacité de poser le bon diagnostic et
donc le bon traitement un traitement
réaliste et bien concrètement on utilise
des artefacts à travers de la dépense
publique les montants que vous avez
évoqué l'âme et qui s'accumulent en fait
après la gestion avec l'escaut vide etc
et qui font que devant nous on a une
véritable mur de dette il faudra un jour
ou l'autre affronter la croissance du
résultat aurait été le même
non
que pour le coup et
c'est là où la casquette mi6 à merveille
tout de même c'est que
la confusion des genres la lnh la taxe
ap le prélèvement forfaitaire unitaire
cemac rang qu'il a fait m'étonnerait que
d'autres les faits on va en reparler
ajustement de la flat tax ce sera juste
après la pub
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine le
bilan de la politique fiscale et sociale
des manuels macron avec pierre sabatier
membres d econoclaste est président du
cabinet prime vous et vous olivier
justement olivier pierre sabatier évoqué
la flat tax juste avant la pub on l'a
dit les 1% les plus riches ont vu leur
pouvoir d'achat augmenter de 2 8% sur le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron qu'il ya
eu la flat tax la suppression de l' isf
est ce que ce sont ces mesures est
seulement ces mesures qui ont enrichi en
gros les plus riches ou est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres paramètres à prendre non c'est
à dire que c'est un aujourd'hui c'est un
phénomène il ya trois ans parce que
c'est un phénomène que vous retrouvez
aux etats unis c'est un phénomène que
vous retrouvez dans beaucoup de deux
pays européens où c'est l'échec flagrant
des soi disant élites qui gouvernent le
monde depuis depuis longtemps donc
on a préféré à un moment là
la dette à tout autre tout autre chose
c'est-à-dire que ces pratiques si vous
voulez là c'est facile en fait c'est
facile c'est à dire que ça évite de se
poser des questions ça évite d'essayer
de prévoir les choses ça évite d'essayer
planifier un certain nombre
d'investissements qui soit vraiment des
investissements et pas les ronds-points
vous faites tous les 100 mètres sur les
routes qui permet de vous parler de la
dette mais comment est-ce qu'on explique
qu'aucune qu' aucune des mesures n'ait
réussi à toucher les plus pauvres mais
parce que quand vous faites de la dette
comme ça et quand vous imprimer des
billets comme ça vous fléchés de fait
sur les gens qui détiennent le capital
donc ça arrive de fait sur les marchés
par exemple l'action ça fait monter les
titres mais ça ne m'apporte rien dans
notre assiette si vous voulez vous si
vous n'avez pas de capital au départ
vous n'avez pas d'immobilier vous n'avez
pas de matières premières chez vous et
vous n'avez pas de 2,2 d'action vous
êtes la farce voilà vous êtes levés d'un
bond de la farce oui on va l'arrêter
pour compléter et bien comprendre ce qui
est des classes populaires qui ont été
conviés des augmentations de pouvoir
d'achat comment on explique que c'est
mais ses défenseurs n'ont cessé
d'efforts au blitz games et des
béquilles mais la réalité c'est que les
43 de sucre et de savourez vos chiffres
le mans sur nous parce que la réalité
les beaucoup le fait de l'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat des plus riches mais
beaucoup plus élevé que ce que vous
évoquez là bas mais c'est pas la
fiscalité c'est pas les cadeaux qui ont
été faits ces larmes qu'on utilise
maintenant le vine presque une quinzaine
d'années une grosse dizaine d'années et
celle en fait de l'impression de monnaie
et surtout l'usagé qu'on en fait l'usagé
qu'on fait de l'impression monétaire
donc ça c'est une décision de politique
de banques centrales mais qu'on peut pas
en fait dissocier d'une politique
budgétaire gouvernemental rappelez vous
toujours qu'une banque centrale c'est
l'émanation du pouvoir politique qu'on
la dise indépendante ou pas c'est
toujours comme ça elle est indépendante
quand elle le peut lorsque ça devient
difficile elle l'est plus et donc elle
est en réalité en soutien des politiques
budgétaires est ce qui fait la richesse
mans et d'accroissement du pouvoir
d'achat des plus riches et par extension
pas d autre part c'est pas les mêmes
levier c'est que ce qu'on fait de la
politique d'impression monétaire c'est
quoi ces de l'administration de prix sur
les marchés financiers et c'est ce
qu'ils votent donc c'est une
valorisation des actifs qui enrichissent
anciennement les plus riches parce
qu'ils se touchent en flux c'est le
stock d'argent c'est leur richesse
globale qui augmente plus qu'en fait les
flux attrait qui se lisent à travers les
chiffres que vous mentionnez là et donc
pourquoi c'est presque amoral non c'est
pas un moral c'est plus immoral jusqu'à
moral cette technique c'est parce que on
aurait très bien pu
mix il faut émettre des tombereaux de
monnaie à m'ont donné imaginons que ce
soit en fait la bonne solution à un
moment donné vous auriez pu vous dire
tiens par exemple les classes populaires
les plus pauvres dans un pays dans
lequel il fait froid l'émission on la
tourne voilà au mois de novembre donc il
fait froid en ce moment donc les gens
chauffent donc la question du chauffage
et de la dépendance énergétique de la
france en gaz et en fuel dans ce que
vous voulez a fait que ça coûte cher
mais pourquoi la prod pour le coup si
vous vraiment vous voulez donner du
pouvoir d'achat aux plus pauvres vous
essayer de limiter les flux financiers
associés en fait au chauffage vous
faites alors on vous dit vous faites des
vous essayez de réfléchir comment vous
monter une filière indépendante des
énergies fossiles que vous importez
d'ailleurs du pétrole du fioul et du gaz
dans ces cas où oui faire partout où
c'est possible de la géothermie en sous
sol oui ça coûte un peu plus cher que
normal mais on imprime des tombereaux de
monnaie une faune car ils firent en gros
la valeur artificielle des actions et
donc enrichir le capital des plus riches
vous auriez voilà fait un plan à 100 ou
200 milliards d'euros à un moment donné
pour cela vous aurez à intrigue mais a
rendu moins dépendants l'autre donner du
pouvoir d'achat aux plus pauvres vous
aurait rendu la filière énergie la
france ont été moins dépendant de ses
importations
quand vous aurez de réduire une partie
de son déficit commercial en tant que
tel et financer une filière un moment
donné alors évidemment faut pas le faire
éternellement mais vous faites sur un
stock pendant un an vous faites ça une
fois que ça c'est fait concrètement cet
argent vous avez écrit il à soutenir les
causes plus un peu plus l'économie
réelle il a été utile parce que ça a
rendu la france un peu moins dépendante
des autres en termes de déficit
commercial est d'une certaine manière
cet argent là il est plus fléchi vers
les populations qui en ont le plus
besoin à savoir les plus pauvres et donc
concrètement c'est pas tellement les
boutiques on donne à l'ailé les miettes
qu'on donne en fait bloc c'est plutôt
avoir en tête qu'est ce qui fait que à
terme on permet justement de faire
monter en gamme toute la population
française et donc les choix des
politiques qu'elles soient budgétaire ou
monétaire elle à la fin et ça le sujet
est-ce que ça sert où ça permet à toute
la société française monte ou est-ce
qu'un était bien on ne fait que créer
des déséquilibres encore un peu plus
lent je crois pas que ce quinquennat la
est permis de réduire les déséquilibres
ou s'il a permis de leur est de les
réduire dans certaines zones c'est avec
des leviers qui sont artificielles qui
ne règle pas le problème à présent sur
le chômage notre
me créer des emplois comme jamais s'est
félicité le chef de l'état dans son
allocution du 9 novembre dernier au
troisième trimestre de cette année le
taux de chômage est estimé par l'insee à
7,6 pour cent c'est quasiment un point
de moins qu'à la même période en 2010 9
avant l'arrivée de la crise sanitaire
donc toujours selon l'insee on compte 96
96 mille créations nettes d'emplois au
troisième trimestre +2 500 mille emplois
ont été créés sur l'ensemble de l'année
2021 les chiffres lui donnent raison lui
et
je vais devenir vulgaire non
non évidemment non c'est à dire les vous
connaissez on a fait des émissions aussi
sur le sur le chômage le chiffre du
chômage ou les fait dire ce que vous
voulez c'est à dire que vous prenez
d'abord la catégorie à vous oublier
évidemment
les
les dom tom et compagnie vous évitez
aussi tous les gens qui se font moins
travail qui représente deux heures par
semaine si vous voulez ou donc bien bien
bien assez peu pour vivre et
bien insuffisant pour vivre et donc vous
sortez évidemment toutes les autres
catégories b c d et c est donc
vous obtenez un chiffre qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec une
quelconque réalité vous avez la même
chose qui se passe aux etats-unis où on
vous dit qu'on est au plein emploi et
puis quand vous regardez réellement les
chiffres malheureusement vous êtes très
très très très loin du plein emploi donc
voilà et c'est bien aussi pour ça que le
le problème des pénuries de deux
salariés n'est pas du tout au fait qu'
on se rapprocherait d'un ample d'un
plein emploi idéal mais parce que parce
que vous avez d'autres problem non on a
simplement maintenu des mesures de
chômage
après le après le soi disant quoi qu'il
en coûte et et d'eau que vous avez en
effet une baisse de la catégorie ya qui
n'est pas la baisse du chômage global et
du sous-emploi globale et etc donc on
est très très loin de pouvoir le
féliciter là dessus alors ils s'auto
félicite faute de félicitations venant
de l'extérieur ça n'est pas anormal
quatre mois avant les élections ou cinq
mois avant les élections il faut s'auto
féliciter pour quelque chose une
dernière réaction l'affirmative sa mise
en cale parce qu'on parle tout le temps
de développement durable ou à la limite
je vais pas discuter de la fiabilité du
chef olivier le fait très bien et
suffisamment dans la question
fondamentale c'est que c'est déjà un la
proximité de ces satisfecit est que ces
bons résultats à proximité d'une
élection c'en est presque pathétique un
ca ses premiers points le deuxième point
c'est la question fondamentale c'est
comment on arrive à ce chiffre encore
une fois on parle de développement
durable est ce que c'est censé emplois
qui seraient créés sont le sont enfin
sont là de manière durable et ça revient
à la question initiale en réalité à quel
prix on arrive à ces chiffres là à quel
prix là combien la dette française
aujourd'hui par un pot en fait un allié
à 50 hier qu'on a utilisé tous des fat
des leviers artificielle avec le summum
de cela étant effectivement le coût
associé aux mesures de chômage partiel
qui en soi sont c'est une bonne idée
mais si elle dure pas trop longtemps
jour paraît une bonne idée transitoire
est exceptionnel il ne faut pas qu'elle
dure longtemps pour qu'elle soit
efficace si ça devient quelque chose de
structurel ça coûte beaucoup plus que ce
que ça rapporte la même manière en fait
les frais garantis par l'état on va
rigoler là c'est marrant c'est bizarre
en fait on va commencer finalement de
les rembourser finalement après
l'élection allez on a rallongé d'un an
le moment à partir duquel on pourra
rembourser les prêts garantis par l'état
donc on va voir si les entreprises qui
aujourd'hui sont situation un peu
meilleure sans capacité d'assumer tous
passif à quel prix à quel prix est ce
que les leviers qu'on utilisait pour
cela sont des leviers durable ont pas ce
matin midi et soir à parler de
développement durable moi la question
que je pose c'est est-ce que les
dépenses publiques nous amène à avoir
une et comique et plus durable
incapacité très suffisamment de richesse
pour que les gens disposaient pouvoir
d'achat et un emploi qui soit durable
merci père savait si olivier on passe
aux commentaires cash
et on commence avec le commentaire de
petits suisses pourquoi l'hydrogène n'a
pas d'avenir comme source d'énergie
olivier écoutez je suis pas ingénieur
donc je peux pas vous répondre
simplement la seule chose qu'on peut
dire sur sur l'hydrogène c'est que en
effet il semblerait que pour l'instant
créer de l'hydrogène
coûte plus cher que
que ce que ça va vous générez comme
énergie aussi donc le le la
transformation ne me paraît pas en effet
quelque chose pour l'instant en tout cas
d'intérêt sans merci olivier pierre
sabatier merci beaucoup d'avoir versé 1
parmi nous je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste membre d econoclaste et
président du cabinet preview va se
retrouver à la semaine prochaine pour
une émission d'ailleurs consacré à la
dette via son rapport avec la croissance
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous donc
la semaine prochaine en attendant
n'oubliez pas de commenter cette
émission sur les réseaux sociaux et
poser vos questions à olivier ses olives
et d'ailleurs c'est un jour l'un des
mots
bilan actif 0 passif 1